worst acting real role of all time you
know
spiders is like
here's a Doritos commercial where the
bag is like spitting and [ __ ] and you
catch it you're on a skateboard
speaking of Pope I've been watching the
tutors
why are you clapping about you watching
I've been watching the tutors I saw
[ __ ] five episodes in two nights and
how is it does Christian like it she
watched the beginning of the first
episode and then was on Tick Tock and
then went to bed and then the second
night she didn't want to do it because
she went to bed
no I'm the best dude but it's all good I
did [ __ ] spin move back downstairs
watch the whole thing and I'm down
[ __ ] watch it I'm watching instead of
her watch it with her I'll watch it with
a friend wow you watched the tutors with
a friend yeah dude you have mental
problems well no it's good you know why
it's good and I will tell you this okay
here's the deal I get it's not very it's
not as thought provoking as it as a show
like that should be okay but I I
wondered why
it's it's just it's watchable first of
all that guy Jonathan is it Jonathan
Rhys Meyers and Reese Myers yeah he is
so obviously not Henry the eighth it's
unbelievable and I heard that he was
like I'm gonna do the part and then
wouldn't put on the fat suit and
wouldn't dye his hair oh dude I hate
that which sucks but also it's like who
cares if they look like the people in
history I guess it adds to it you agree
no I fully agree oh you do fully agree
that it doesn't matter what they look
like when people get so caught up in
like with Rey with Jamie Foxx everyone's
like he looks just like them Anthony
Hopkins and Nixon he looks just like a
Bull gives a [ __ ] they're acting I know
me I know I spend your [ __ ] disbelief
exactly exactly let me play Richard
Nixon well I'm not a crook but anyway uh
so I watch the tutors and the only
reason why I watch that show is because
Eric Griffin keeps telling me okay about
this scene
okay where there's a guy whose job it is
to catch how do we not get [ __ ] age
restricted for this or demonetized to
catch the king's
um
spillage when he uh-huh
yeah and he just sits there with her
when he does the come job thing and he
goes like this and then over he goes
like this and he goes like this and
folds it and he leaves that's his whole
role that's his job worst role worst
acting real role of all time you know
tutors I played uh Jonathan Rhys Meyers
is [ __ ] come Joby collector and uh
come Joby dude it was a great experience
uh yeah oh wow dude that's amazing just
just this and it shows it shows you it
like one one it shows one thing where
you play the neighbor in According to
Jim right and then one thing where
you're just like and then a Doritos
commercial and Jonathan
and the juddison respires I was like and
you're just like quarterback
thank you sir and the next thing is the
Doritos commercial where the bag is like
spitting and [ __ ] and you catch it
you're on a skateboard yeah yeah yeah oh
wow best [ __ ] acting real of all time
[Music]
hello
hello